à tous
monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues madame monsieur
la mission d'information sur le bâtisse
scolaire à l'épreuve de la transition
écologique c'est constituée le 7 février
dernier
à l'initiative du groupe du
Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants de notre
rapporteur madame avait et membre
l'objectif de notre mission est
d'évaluer les besoins de rénovation des
écoles collèges et lycée
lié à la transition écologique
d'identifier les défis notamment au
juridiques et financiers de cette
rénovation pour les collectivités
territoriales et d'apprécier
l'efficacité de l'accompagnement des
décideurs locaux s'agissant plus
particulièrement de l'accès à
l'information et à l'expertise
notre rapport assorti de recommandations
devrait être rendu public
en juin 2023
dès notre première réunion notre
collègue Yann chanterelle
sénateur représentant les Français
établis hors de France
a attiré notre attention sur la
situation des établissements français à
l'étranger et sur la nécessité
d'intégrer cette problématique à nos
réflexions
Nadège avait rapporté et moi-même nous
sommes adressés à Ronan Lele président
du groupe
d'études statues rôle et place des
Français établis en France pour lui
proposer de travailler ensemble à cette
problématique
il a spontanément exprimé de l'intérêt
pour l'autre demande ce dont je le
remercie ainsi cette audition est
organisée en commun avec notre mission
d'information et par le groupe d'études
du Sénat dédié aux Français établis hors
de France
nous accueillons donc ensemble le Sénat
Monsieur Olivier brochet directeur
pardon directeur de l'agence de
l'enseignement français à l'étranger
madame Odile Hagen Muller directrice de
l'immobilier de l'agence de
l'enseignement français étranger ainsi
que Monsieur Jean-Marc Mériot directeur
général de la Mission laïque française
mesdames et messieurs je rappelle que
cette audition donnera lieu à un compte
rendu écrit qui sera annexé à notre
rapport et que son enregistrement vidéo
sera accessible sur le site du Sénat
après les interventions de Monsieur
Leleu et de Madame ave rapporteur de la
mission d'information vous aurez la
parole pour une dizaine de minutes
chacun puis nous aurons un temps
d'échange étant entendu que le tout
devra être achevé pour
15 heures moins deux minutes
- 5 l'ascenseur est en panne
je passe la parole à notre collègue
bien merci monsieur le Président Madame
la rapporteur chers collègues je vous
remercie d'avoir associé notre groupe
d'études staturo les places des Français
établis hors de France à vos travaux
pour cette audition consacrée au bâti
scolaire des établissements
d'enseignements français à l'étranger
sur le directeur général chez le
directeur mesdames je vous remercie
d'avoir accepté donc notre invitation
pour aborder avec nous ce sujet d'un
abord un peu technique le sujet présente
à notre sens un intérêt réel pour les
établissements d'enseignement français à
l'étranger alors que le Président de la
République lors de son discours à
l'Institut de France en 2018 a fixé
l'objectif de doubler les effectifs des
élèves bénéficiant de l'enseignement
français à l'étranger à l'horizon 2030
que l'on appelle le cap 2030 ce qui
signifierait donc de pouvoir accueillir
à terme 700 000 élèves
nos collègues Jean-Yves Lecomte et Yann
chanterelles à la fois membre du groupe
d'études et de la mission d'information
ont eu raison de suggérer que nous nous
y penchions en effet si l'objectif fixé
devait être atteint les défis en termes
de bâti sont considérables cela suppose
la construction de nouveaux
établissements ou ce qui est assez
fréquent des travaux d'agrandissement ou
d'extension qui peuvent parfois
contraindre à changer de site en effet
rappelons qu'au moment du du discours du
président de la République le nombre
d'élèves étaient approximativement de
350 000 à l'échelle du réseau et nous
sommes aujourd'hui à 390
000 élèves dans l'enseignement français
à l'étranger dans 567 lycée français qui
sont de nature extrêmement différentes
mais je pense que vous allez
parfaitement expliquer cela
établissement gestion directe
conventionnée partenaires et où la
gestion la politique que la EFE peut
mener notamment sur le bâti scolaire
évidemment n'est pas du tout la même et
il est important de pouvoir distinguer
les trois types d'établissements
homologués dans le réseau oui cette
audition nous permet d'aborder le sujet
de l'essor de l'enseignement français à
l'étranger sous un angle très concret
nous sommes très impatients d'entendre
la EFE l'Agence pour l'enseignement
français à l'étranger et la MLF la
Mission laïque française sur ce sujet un
peu technique mais certainement très
instructif et éclairant puis nous aurons
un échange avec très certainement de
nombreuses questions je vous remercie
même la rapporteur merci monsieur le
Président donc depuis le début de nos
travaux en fait on a auditionné un
certain nombre de personnes que ce soit
universitaires représentant de la
communauté éducative entreprise du
bâtiment structure accompagnant des
collectivités territoriales et j'en
passe d'autres auditions sont également
effectivement au programme notre mission
d'information elle compte deux sénateurs
établis à l'étranger il nous semblait
important pour avoir une bonne vision
qu'on puisse effectivement
travailler sur ce champ là et également
ne pas oublier la dimension
ultramarine
que l'on a également puisqu'on a un
certain nombre de sénateurs qui sont qui
sont dans des
départements d'outre-mer
ça nous semble important d'avoir votre
regard parce qu'on n'est pas du tout sur
les mêmes problématiques en fait que
l'on va avoir ici que ce soit sur le
champ climatique mais aussi sur le champ
règlement réglementaire notamment avec
un cadre juridique qui est qui est
spécifique donc je vais vous je remercie
Yann chanterelle pardon j'allais oublier
mais je tiens à te remercier parce qu'on
en a effectivement en parler des la mise
en place de la mission et tu nous a
permis effectivement d'avoir d'être mis
en relation pour pouvoir avoir les
bonnes interlocuteurs autour de la table
donc je vous laisse la parole
voilà merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Madame la rapporteur monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrice et sénateurs donc je ferai une
présentation à deux fois avec ma
collègueille Odile again Müller qui à
l'agence et sous directrice de
l'immobilier et qui complétera mon
propos je voudrais tout d'abord
peut-être
en excuse auprès des sénateurs des
Français de l'étranger qui connaîtront
par coeur les mes propos mais peut-être
pour les sénatrices des sénateurs qui
connaissent moins notre réseau
effectivement souligner les spécificités
de ce réseau et la mission qui est celle
de l'agence qui est l'opérateur public
en charge de ce réseau de l'enseignement
français à l'étranger c'est un réseau
constitué effectivement de 567
établissements qui sont présents dans
138 pays et qui sont de statuts très
divers
68 de ces établissements sont des
établissements en gestion direct de
l'agence qui scolarisent pratiquement
120 000 élèves sur les 3
[Musique]
établissements qui peuvent dépendre de
groupes éducatifs et parmi ces groupes
éducatifs le plus important est
effectivement la Mission laïque est une
association que Jean-Marc vous
présentera et qui historiquement
d'ailleurs la plus vieille organisation
dans le dans le réseau et qui ont leur
propre responsabilité là encore en
termes de gestion alors l'agence a une
responsabilité
particulière à l'égard de ces
établissements gestion direct puisque
leur met pleinement responsable et c'est
à l'égard de ces établissements
évidemment que ces responsabilités sont
plus engagées sur les questions d'ordre
immobilier mais à l'égard des autres
établissements du réseau à l'admission
d'ensemble qui est de faire vivre ce
réseau de s'assurer de la qualité de ce
qui se fait pour le compte du ministère
de l'Éducation nationale dans le cadre
du respect de l'homologation qui est
donnée par le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale nous avons une mission
d'animation de formation pour très
personnel et puis une mission je dirais
qui est un petit peu général qui est de
diffuser les bonnes pratiques les
valeurs que l'État souhaite pour son
réseau éducatif ça vaut évidemment au
plan pédagogique ça vaut aussi sur des
questions qui sont liées à celles du
développement durable et je citerai à
titre d'exemple le fait que nous avons
adapté le dispositif de labellisation
développement durable qui a été
développée en France nous l'avons adapté
pour l'étranger et donc il y a
maintenant un label qui s'appelle efe3d
enseignement français à l'étranger
développement durable qui est un label
que nous attribuons il y a actuellement
je crois 120 lycées qui en ont bénéficié
et qui consiste surtout à la
mobilisation des communautés éducatives
autour d'objectifs de développement
durable ce n'est pas un label qui porte
spécifiquement sur les questions de bâti
il est plus sur l'action pédagogique je
dirais mais lorsque les établissements
tendent vers la troisième degré de
puisqu'il y a trois degrés de
labellisation évidemment il sont obligés
d'avoir une réflexion globale sur leur
impact
leur impact écologique et donc
d'intégrer éventuellement des
transformations de cette nature donc
voilà pour cadrer très rapidement pour
vous dire aussi évidemment que d'une
part
pour l'ensemble de ce réseau le
financement de l'immobilier et la
question la plus sensible la plus
délicate pour la pour l'Agence pour
l'enseignement français à l'étranger
donc à la responsabilité de ses 68 EGD
nous sommes confrontés à une difficulté
que le sénateur ou les sénateurs des
Français de l'étranger connaissent bien
c'est que depuis 2010 nous n'avons plus
de capacité d'emprunt reconnu par la loi
au contraire nous avons été classés
comme interdits
ce qui nous pose un énorme problème pour
financer le développement et l'entretien
de ce réseau et évidemment nous pose un
problème que l'on retrouvera sur les
questions de bâti c'est une
problématique général qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui le financement de
l'entretien et du développement du
réseau des EGD qui sont des réseaux qui
est un réseau d'État repose à plus de
80% sur le financement des familles
pour les établissements
conventionnés et pour les établissements
partenaires là c'est d'emblée un
financement qui est à 100% par les
établissements et donc par les familles
j'ai oublié de dire que tout ce réseau
de l'enseignement français à l'étranger
est un réseau qui est payant les
familles doivent payer des droits de
scolarité qui est en moyenne sont de
l'ordre de 6000 euros par an mais c'est
une moyenne qui va de quelques centaines
d'euros pour les établissements les plus
modestes à Madagascar jusqu'à maintenant
plus de 40000 euros pour le lycée de San
Francisco donc on a une très très grande
variété mais c'est aux établissements
évidemment de financer alors l'agence
pour soutenir les établissements
je dirais un peu pour nos EGD nous
sommes obligés de constituer des fonds
de réserve dans les établissements que
nous constituons progressivement pour
pouvoir faire les investissements
immobiliers ce qui est très difficile et
qui aujourd'hui va devenir quasiment
impossible dans une période de très
forte inflation des coûts que nos
établissements ressentent et à l'égard
des autres établissements du réseau
conventionnés ou partenaires nous
pouvons attribuer des subventions mais
de mon temps relativement modeste de
nous avons un budget de subvention pour
le réseau que qui cette année va être de
l'ordre de 15 millions d'euros aussi mis
en travaux de sécurité qu'en travaux
d'aide au développement donc rapporté à
l'ensemble des établissements ça reste
assez modeste voilà pour pour ce cadrage
général sur l'agence et ce réseau est
donc notre présentation sera focalisée
sur les OGD puisque ce sont ceux que
nous avons en pleine responsabilité et
donc je vais laisser la parole à Odile
pour vous présenter en quelques lignes
contre politique sur les OGD sur la
question du bâti
j'ai juste une question que vous nous
avez donné le nombre d'élèves mais ma
curiosité me dit mais et le nombre de
professeurs alors le nombre de
professeurs alors l'ensemble des
personnels travaillant pour
l'enseignement français à l'étranger
c'est entre 40 et 45000 personnes à peu
près dont 11000 qui travaillent pour
l'agence pour l'agence nous avons 6000
fonctionnaires et un peu plus de 5000
recrutés locaux dans nos établissements
et donc les 30000 autres personnels qui
travaillent dans le réseau sont des
personnels recrutés localement par tous
les établissements qui le constituent
voilà donc il s'agit donc d'un
patrimoine caractéristique sur 68gd
c'est une coquille sur le titre de la
slide réparti dans 25 pays nos EGD sont
sur 25 pays donc ce sont des
établissements d'enseignement général
pour tous qui vont de la maternelle au
secondaire et constitue un patrimoine
d'environ 600 000 m² sur la totalité les
implantations dans le monde
majoritairement au Maghreb et au Maroc
et des époques de construction
mais en Europe et des époques de
construction assez récentes on a
quelques bâtiments très anciens et
globalement une majorité de construction
qui date des années 70 et 2000 à partir
du moment où on a fait des extensions et
des et des créations des architectures
qui s'adaptent et s'inspirent du local
mais qui concerne la marque d'une
organisation des espaces à la française
et qui sont constitués de petits
bâtiments souvent pas haut et donc un
peu étalé sur le parcellaire
leur qualité technique et aujourd'hui
plutôt moyenne
ce sont des bâtiments qui sont peu
isolés un peu isolés avec de bonnes
qualités toutes fois de
d'organisation spatiale les sites
disposent d'une importation
historiquement sur nos OGD plutôt
prestigieuses pour des sites qui sont
souvent dans les meilleures qualités et
les capitales des villes
voilà alors là peut-être voilà la
spécificité en dehors de cette
éparpillement de ces 68 j'étais dans 25
pays la première qui vaut pour tout le
réseau d'ailleurs c'est que la première
des normes qui s'impose à nous c'est les
normes des pays et donc nous ne
devons travailler dans certains pays les
normes sont beaucoup plus élevés que
celles que nous avons en France dans
beaucoup il y en a pas beaucoup
nettement moins et donc la première
référence c'est la norme du pays après
ça nous voyons si nous pouvons aller
au-delà en nous inspirant évidemment des
pratiques françaises ça c'est la
première chose que je voulais souligner
la deuxième chose c'est que de notre
patrimoine se répartit dans des zones
qui en tout cas du point de vue
climatique sont extrêmement différents
de Stockholm à Niamey ou à des
établissements d'Afrique tropicale
évidemment nous sommes avec des
conditions générales qui sont qui sont
extrêmement variées
les établissements actuellement les
établissements d'Europe en particulier
subissent une explosion des coûts liée
aux fournitures d'énergie pendant
l'exemple du lycée de La Haye au Pays
Basque au printemps à l'automne dernier
qui était avec une facture d'énergie qui
avait déjà augmenté de 70 % le gaz le
gaz augmentait énormément donc ils sont
tous confrontés à ça mais dans le même
temps gardera l'esprit qu'on a beaucoup
d'établissements qui n'ont pas des
problèmes de chauffage mais des
problèmes de refroidissement et de
climatisation et que faire travailler
les enfants dans des contextes
évidemment très chaud c'est coûteux et
c'est un énorme problème pour beaucoup
d'établissements donc notre approche
elle doit tenir compte de ces questions
elle doit tenir compte ensuite de la
capacité évidemment à faire des travaux
qui intègrent toutes les normes
bioclimatiques que l'on peut développer
dans nos pays c'est-à-dire de trouver
les équipes d'architectes capables de
faire les équipes de
qui vont pouvoir construire de pouvoir
importer les matériels qui sont aux
normes correspondantes à nos besoins etc
donc il y a à chaque fois chaque projet
est un projet extrêmement complexe et
Odile comme comme Jean-Marc à la MLF
pourra développer évidemment ses points
là et donc toute la difficulté c'est à
la fois d'assurer pour dans un certain
nombre de pays en Afrique au Maghreb au
Moyen-Orient des conditions de travail
qui soient quand même satisfaisante pour
nos élèves et je note parfois une
contradiction entre évidemment nos
élèves qui sont très à la pointe en
termes de demandes d'amélioration de
l'impact écologique de nos
établissements mais qui dans le même
temps eux ou leurs familles sont aussi
très attentifs à ce que les conditions
de travail restent bonnes et donc
supprimer la climatisation par exemple
dans un établissement même quand on
réussit et parce qu'on réussit à
construire des beaux projets on pourra
en parler ça demande beaucoup de
pédagogie pour conv que ça va marcher et
quand ça ne marche pas bien on a eu le
cas à Tunis au mois de septembre l'année
dernière sur des bâtiments qui ont été
rénovés mais où manifestement ça ne
suffit pas ça crée des tensions extrêmes
dans le dans nos écoles ça c'est la
première chose on a une spécificité
aussi qui est question de qualité de
l'air dans les établissements alors
c'est une problématique qui peut être
généralisée mais alors qui est hyper
sensible dans les établissements d'Asie
ou les les familles les personnels les
élèves sont très sensibles à la qualité
de l'air respirer dans dans des pays
très très pollués ça vaut à Pékin par
exemple ou l'établissement est obligé de
fonctionner avec une purification
permanente de l'air mais ça vaut dans
beaucoup d'autres endroits et puis bon
en Europe on a des standards européens
dans les pays là qui s'imposent dans le
cadre de nos rénovations qu'on doit
intégrer et qui vont parfois au-delà de
des standards que nous avons ici donc
voilà un petit peu toutes ces toutes ces
problématiques auxquelles on doit faire
face qui nous oblige en fait
avoir une approche globale
j'ajouterai que nous sommes avec nous
sommes dans l'obligation de présenter un
schéma pureuré annuel d'investissement
le SPSI nous en avons c'est un programme
quinquennal nous en avons déjà proposé
deux nous sommes en train de finaliser
le troisième les deux premiers aspic qui
ont été présentés n'intégrez pas
spécifiquement des questions relatives
aux normes aux normes
bio-climatique etc ce qui nous a pas
empêché de faire des réalisations en
tenant compte et Odile va vous en
présenter une mais en revanche le
nouveau aspsi sur lequel nous
travaillons intégrera une dimension
écologique bioclimatique pour tous les
projets qui vont être développés
donc nous vous proposons d'illustrer ces
propos par un exemple qui est ce que
nous avons réalisé au lycée français
Charles lepierre de Lisbonne pour lequel
les objectifs
étaient les suivantes permettent
l'accueil toujours dans notre objectif
aussi de développement de nouveaux
élèves de réaliser un projet durable et
sobre et de redonner de la lisibilité
aussi et de rationner l'utilisation de
l'espace et en améliorer son usage donc
c'est une parcelle originale et
originelle qui fait 22000 mètres carrés
qui est situé sur une des collines de
camp Polyte pour ceux qui connaissent et
qui comprenait donc ça c'est l'état
initial des corps de bâtiment de 1952
un peu éparpillé sur le site
un manque de lieu de vie un inconfort
total des bâtiments provisoires sans
doute
et donc à la suite de quoi on a lancé
une consultation maîtriseur par concours
on a il a été sélectionné l'équipe mais
endre TC c'est écrit en haut qui est un
groupement d'architectes enfin de
maîtrise d'oeuvre consulter d'un bureau
d'études français
ainsi que portugais et puis un maître
d'oeuvre mandataire français
et pour ce projet donc les axes de
l'éco-construction que nous souhaitions
étaient les suivants la sobriété
énergétique pour une consommation
inférieure et je rentre un peu dans des
chiffres techniques pour ceux qui
connaissent 90 kilowatts d'énergie
primaire par mètre carré par an pas de
climatisation une conception
bioclimatique par orientation des bâties
et mise en place de protection solaire
une qualité de l'air et un travail sur
la circulation naturelle de l'air avec
un free cooling à l'intérieur des
espaces
pédagogiques une construction pour cela
de trois bâtiments neufs en a qui ont
permis d'agrandir des espaces
pédagogiques
et d'agrandir aussi des cours de
récréation et de donner bien sûr une
forte lis une meilleure lisibilité aussi
au site une utilisation de matériaux bio
sur
C en circuit court avec un produit phare
de local qui est le lait le liège en
isolation pour les murs et le sol et des
pierres de façade sur les murs en
[Musique]
pour la construction que vous voyez ici
et puis bien sûr et encore l'utilisation
d'un Béto béton initial qui est conservé
sur les structures qu'on a gardé et
qu'on a reconstruit pour
les grandes portées quand c'était
nécessaire donc ça c'est le résultat
je rentre un peu dans les détails donc
aujourd'hui en termes de de coûts et de
résultats chiffrés on est sur un une
consommation d'énergie primaire qui est
inférieure à l'objectif qu'on s'était
fixé pour ceux qui connaissent c'est un
bon chiffre
mais par rapport aux objectifs de
développement durable qu'on a en Europe
dans le cadre du Cap 2030 on est encore
au dessus aujourd'hui on est pour des
bâtiments neufs il faudrait qu'on soit à
30 kW l'énergie primaire par mètre carré
par an par choix et par an voilà
donc je continue donc le travail précis
et technique qui a été fait sur le
travail de la circulation de l'air et de
la minimisation des de l'effet de serre
était de travailler sur la mise en place
de brise-soleil qui permettent
d'atténuer les effets du soleil et de
s'isoler du froid si nécessaire
sur les salles de classe avec des
brise-soleil amovibles
qui sont utilisables par les
usagers
on a mis en place un travail donc sur
les brisolaires mais aussi sur les
fenêtres avec des ouvrants enfin des
châssis fixes
constitués de jalousies amovibles qui
permettent de faire circuler l'air la
nuit lorsque le bâtiment est fermé de
façon à créer enfin en magasiner de
l'air frais en été et d'avoir de l'air
frais en arrivant le matin
et en évitant d'avoir donc de la
climatisation en rajoutant des
ventilateurs au plafond qui crée de la
circulation de cet air frais on a
puisque la démarche de développement
durable et aussi une démarche globale on
a travaillé avec les utilisateurs on a
fait des ateliers pour qu'ils puissent
s'approprier aussi
l'organisation de l'espace qu'on leur
proposait et de travailler avec eux sur
les équipements et puis la configuration
des salles de classe au quotidien
donc là je vous passe quelques photos du
chantier pour que vous voyez donc à
droite les isolations en liège à gauche
la maçonnerie en briques qui est un
matériau intéressant pour son inertie
la pierre locale qui est une pierre de
Lisbonne qui a donc été mis en plaquage
sur les
façades extérieures
le travail a aussi toujours avec le
liège mais cette fois en revêtement de
sol sur les sols pour améliorer
l'isolation
sonore des salles
donc seuls les plafonds
voilà la mise en place des fameux
brise-soleil et des fenêtres en jalousie
dont j'évoquais
un travail aussi très important sur les
j'en ai pas trop parlé sur le dessin des
cours et puis l'infiltration de l'eau
sur ses cours qui permettent donc une
filtration
et puis le résultat final
d'accès aux salles de classe
voilà alors cette opération de Lisbonne
c'est la dernière qui a été achevée elle
sera l'inauguration officielle aura lieu
dans 15 jours
mais il est déjà en fonction depuis la
rentrée dernière on a eu comme je vous
le disais Mike bien que le SP ici ne
fixe pas d'objectif global les dernières
réalisations ont été faites aussi en
tenant en travaillant dans ce sens je
voudrais citer juste l'exemple de
l'école maternelle du lycée français de
Madrid qui est certainement l'une des
plus grandes écoles maternelles que l'on
ait puisqu'il y a plus de 600 élèves
dans cette maternelle et qui a été faite
sans climatisation et trois ans après
l'usage montre qu'on a réussi le pari
donc le travail des architectes a été
efficace c'était pas gagné et à
l'origine il y avait beaucoup de
scepticisme mais ça a marché et comme je
vous le dis dans certains cas dans
certaines rénovations le travail qui est
fait les résultats sont pas toujours
à la hauteur voilà pour ce qui est des
EGD puis comme je vous le disais donc il
y a les établissements conventionnés
lorsqu'ils se lancent des projets il y a
une volonté générale d'essayer
d'améliorer évidemment ces conditions
notre service immobilier intervient
comme conseil dans ces cas là et donc
nous pouvons les encourager c'est très
parmi les établissements conventionnés
par exemple les établissement de
Djibouti qui est actuellement
construction une reconstruction complète
qui est un établissement qui est parti
d'emblée sur un projet bioclimatique
vraiment très innovant il ne pourra pas
vivre complètement sans climatisation
compte tenu du climat mais l'objectif
c'est de baisser énormément l'utilage de
la climatisation elle est vraiment les
plantes étaient constituées de cette
façon là voilà je vais m'arrêter là bien
entendu nous sommes à votre disposition
pour toute question merci je propose à
Monsieur Mériot de poursuivre et je
salue la présence de Monsieur
chanterelle qui n'est pas membre de
notre émission mais qui est en plus
j'avais deux fois vous avez deux fois
raison d'être
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs merci pour cette invitation je
suis accompagné aujourd'hui de Stéphane
et Rabou qui est la responsable du
département immobilier de du réseau MLF
monde et donc il y a en charge de
coordonnées l'ensemble de la politique
immobilière de l'association pour vous
rappeler un peu
l'association donc c'est une association
historique elle a 120 ans d'histoire
et elle est amenée à bien évidemment
participer à la politique publique de
mise en place par le gouvernement depuis
de nombreuses années c'est une
association d'utilités publiques
financée à autofinancer à hauteur de 95%
de son budget et donc nous avons et nous
gérons actuellement
32 établissements en pleine
responsabilité qui sont le pendant des
établissements en gestion direct de la
de la fe pardon et donc
c'est des établissements où nous avons
la totalité la responsabilité comme je
plais souvent à le rappeler nous gérons
tout du sol au plafond dans ces
établissements et nous avons 66
établissements
partenaires et donc ça ça constitue le
réseau des établissements homologués
que nous accompagnons dans le monde nous
sommes présents dans 37 pays et donc
nous sommes amenés à bien évidemment
alors là je vais me focaliser sur comme
ça a été le cas pour l'AFE sur les 32
établissements en pleine responsabilité
donc nous avons 32 sites sur ces sites
si on rajoute aussi le siège parisien
puisque nous avons nous sommes localisés
dans le 15e avec un site parisien et
donc nous avons alors une particularité
c'est que nous sommes propriétaires de
12% de nos de nos de ces de ces
disciples
et
nous avons
une particularité puisque le reste de
la localisation et là où sont installés
nos établissements sont souvent des
terrains qui sont soit mises à
disposition par les États à travers des
accords bilatérales
d'état ou avec des accords propres à la
Mission laïque française ou des
locations de terrain nous ne sommes pas
très souvent en tout cas nous sommes
majoritairement pas propriétaire des
terrains cependant nous avons aussi la
responsabilité du propriétaire sur la
totalité de ces 32 établissements
voilà exactement mais alors après on
peut se retrouver aussi dans des
configurations ou même dans la mise à
disposition de terrain par des
gouvernements
les pays qui nous accueillent des
baillent et on peut être amené à rendre
les établissements même si nous avons
été amenés à effectuer des
investissements dans ces établissements
alors pour vous faire un petit tour
d'horizon sur tout ce qu'on a eu en
place sur un plan d'action puisque cette
question bien évidemment du de la
gestion du patrimoine immobilier et est
une question aussi très présente pour
pour l'association et donc on a mis en
place ces dernières années toute une
politique volontariste pour nous
permettre de pouvoir bien accompagner
chacun nos établissements dans la
gestion de notre patrimoine donc on a
effectué plusieurs choses on estime
qu'une grande partie de ces de cette
gestion patrimoniale doit s'effectuer au
plus près du terrain donc nous avons des
directions régionales administratives
financières et immobilière dans un
certain nombre de nos réseaux pour nous
permettre de pouvoir faire que ces
directions régionales soient en lien
direct aussi avec les spécificités entre
autres réglementaires puisque comme ça
déjà été souligné c'est vrai que c'est
spécificité réglementaires sont propres
à chacun des pays et à chacun des
réseaux et donc il nous faut là aussi
avoir des compétences spécifiques en
lien avec ce qui peut se passer dans
chacun des
le territoire donc ça c'est des
directions régionales ont été ont mis en
place en 2019 et nous avons créé aussi
un appartement avec donc Stéphanie Rabou
qui est architecte à la responsabilité
depuis 2021
nous avons à travers la mise en place de
toute cette stratégie immobilière mis en
place des audits de batimentaire et donc
nous avons fait un état des lieux et
diagnostic sur les bâtiments en
s'appuyant sur des bureaux d'études
locaux
et donc nous avons été amenés à faire
des diagnostics et préconisations sur
l'ensemble de nos bâtiments avec un plan
d'action associé
sur des enjeux d'ordre sécuritaire dans
un premier temps mais au-delà de ça bien
évidemment ça a intégré aussi des enjeux
qui pouvaient allier toutes les
questions sur des enjeux
environnementaux et donc nous avons été
amenés à pouvoir effectuer des plans
annuels d'investissement sur une
quinzaine d'années aujourd'hui pour
permettre là aussi de travailler à moyen
terme sur ces enjeux immobiliers nous
avons lancé des audits énergétiques dans
l'ensemble de nos établissements c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui sur le sur tout nos
établissements en pleine responsabilité
nous avons fait des bilans énergétiques
des consommations existantes pour avoir
une vision précise de ce qui est des
consommations de nos établissements et
des études de performance énergétique
avec des préconisations d'équipements et
de rénovation de l'ensemble de nos
établissements qui s'intègrent dans les
enjeux de du plan pluriel
d'investissement des estimations bien
évidemment des travaux avec des enjeux
autour de l'estimation des consommations
futures et des retours aussi sur
investissement possible puisque à la
différence c'est vrai de l'AFE étant un
organisation privée nous avons une
capacité d'investissement et une
possibilité aussi de d'avoir des retours
d'investissement à partir du moment où
nous faisons des gains énergétiques
importants sur nos sur nos
établissements
donc sur les projets immobiliers c'est
vrai que nous sommes amenés à voilà nous
avons trois projets actuellement qui
sont des nouveaux projets qui vont faire
l'objet alors qui sont soit des
établissements existants que nous sommes
amenés à rénover ou étendre soit des
constructions neuves
souligner aussi à travers entre autres
notre capacité d'investissement nous
avons été amenés à souscrire auprès de
pro parcours donc une agence de en tout
cas une filiale le lived
un prêt de 60 millions d'euros pour
pouvoir accompagner la construction de
ces nouveaux établissements et c'est
prêt ce prêt et contraint à tout un
dispositif en tout cas à un certain
nombre de normes environnementales donc
nous sommes contraints à travers le en
tout cas de l'octroi de se prélat à
devoir respecter les normes EN
environnementale qui sont voilà les
normes internationales mais voilà qui
font que
on doit là aussi avec un prisme très
précis en tout cas un focus prêt très
très précis et un suivi très précis de
Proparco qui est dans le cadre de sa
charte de près intègre cette dimension
Avignon environnemental et social au
premier plan et donc à contrario avec ce
prêt de 60 millions d'euros d'emprunt
nous avons eu une subvention de 2,5
millions d'euros pour nous accompagner
dans la rénovation d'établissements
existants donc Proparco nous a
accompagné aussi pour nous permettre de
pouvoir là encore
améliorer un certain nombre de nos
établissements et là à travers de la
subvention
donc
ce qui dans nos projets que nous sommes
amenés à pouvoir mettre en place
[Musique]
donc sur le pour revenir un peu sur le
plan pluriel d'investissement donc là
sur la mise en conformité
nous avons été amenés à pouvoir réaliser
des PPI et
aujourd'hui nous PPI couvre à peu près
plus de 60% de nos établissements donc
on continue à travailler sur la mise en
place de ces PPI
sur deux de nos gros réseaux nous avons
terminé le travail sur le réseau Maroc
et sur le réseau Espagne
nous avons aussi fait tout un audit
énergétique sur un autre de nos gros
réseaux qui est le réseau libanais vous
savez que le Liban connaît une crise
systémique et une crise économique
sociale et on pourrait c'est qualifié
d'environnemental puisque il y a des
enjeux aussi très forts sur les
questions environnementales au Liban et
donc
le prix bien évidemment des fluides à
exploser pour pas dire voilà et
dans des augmentations totalement
exponentielles et donc nous avons
effectué un audit énergétique surtout
nos établissements au Liban pour
permettre de les équiper en
photovoltaïques et donc nous avons déjà
établi un plan alors ne cherchons
aujourd'hui les financements la EFE a
prévu dans le cadre de des aides qu'elle
peut octroyer aux établissements
conventionnés puisque nos établissements
Libanais sont des établissements
conventionnés avec l'AFE et de pouvoir
accompagner aussi ces investissements
lourds et nous avons nous sommes aussi
alors dernièrement nous avons été amenés
à construire un établissement scolaire
neuf en Espagne à Palma
en 2021 et donc nous avons là aussi
respecté l'ensemble de la réglementation
thermique et environnementale expert
espagnol et là aussi nous sommes dans
l'étude de pouvoir équiper l'ensemble de
l'établissement de panneaux
photovoltaïques nous sommes dans des
endroits où le gain peut être réel
nous sommes nous avons aussi été amenés
à construire un nouvel établissement à
Rabat au Maroc
deux établissements à Rabat et à Rabat
c'est c'est Malraux et donc nous avons
été amenés à pouvoir faire que nous
puissions là aussi respecter l'ensemble
des
normes de performances
environnementales et nous avons la
certification environnementale HQ HQE
avec un niveau très bon en tout cas ce
qui est qualifié comme étant un des
traits une labellisation de très haut
niveau
donc ensuite nous avons
des projets voilà que nous qui vont de
déclic qui vont voir le jour dans les
trois prochaines années
nous avons un établissement à Séville et
donc là l'architecture l'architecte a
été
choisie et nous avons été amenés alors
on n'a pas été amené à réaliser
l'ensemble en tout cas de vous faire un
petit PowerPoint avec l'ensemble du
descriptif mais c'est vrai que la
dimension environnementale est a été le
choix premier pour retenir le projet
architectural et donc là aussi nous
avons en circuit court puisque ça
s'appuie aussi pour où sur des enjeux de
circuits courts parce que il faut aussi
comprendre que dans les dans les pays
dans lesquels nous sommes implantés nous
avons des gros problèmes de
d'approvisionnement très souvent des
difficultés d'approvisionnement alors
c'est un peu moins vrai pour l'Espagne
mais si vous voilà un de nos autres gros
projets et Addis-Abeba en particulier et
si vous êtes à 10 Habiba il est très
difficile de pouvoir recourir à des
matériaux que vous êtes amené à importer
et donc du coup ça crée aussi des
contraintes supplémentaires des coûts
supplémentaires importants et donc il
faut aussi intégrer ces dimensions là
dans le cas de nos projets
bâtimentsaires et donc là aujourd'hui
même si on sait que nous allons avoir un
coût supplémentaire pour Addis-Abeba
nous intégrons bien évidemment aussi la
certification
environnementale Edge pour nous
permettre de pouvoir faire que nous
respections là aussi à l'international
c'est normes de performance donc
Séville a dit-abeba l'Egypte où nous
sommes amenés aussi là à
faire que nous puissions en tout cas
nous allons reconstruire un
établissement dans sa totalité
à Alexandrie et donc et donc
et là aussi nous sommes sur une
certification HQE avec toujours un
financement pro parcours nous sommes
amenés aussi à avoir des projets
aujourd'hui de développement
et en particulier nous avons un des
modèles sur lequel nous travaillons
actuellement dans un certain nombre de
pays c'est
un travail avec des investisseurs qui
sont amenés à construire les bâtiments
et qui nous donne un mandat de gestion
sur
l'établissement donc nous n'avons pas la
responsabilité de la construction des
des établissements en eux-mêmes mais
nous exigeons pour rentrer en
partenariat avec ses partenaires et ses
investisseurs le fait qu'il respecte
l'ensemble des normes environnementales
donc ça c'est voilà
d'accompagnons pas ces projets là si
eux-mêmes ne sont pas amenés à respecter
l'ensemble de ses normes c'est le cas en
Égypte par exemple ou c'est le cas aussi
au Maroc avec d'autres projets de
développement donc tout ces critères
font partie intégrante aussi en tout cas
nos choix de partenariat s'intègrent
aussi cette dimension environnementale
et donc c'est vrai que ça fait là aussi
en fin de compte nous sommes là aussi
comme on accompagne l'ensemble de ces
acteurs sur ces normes environnementales
et nous sommes amenés à pouvoir leur
octroyer une un service ou une aide pour
permettre de faire que ils puissent
aussi bien respecter l'ensemble de ce
qui constitue les spécificités d'un
établissement scolaire et en termes de
programmation que des enjeux
environnementaux donc c'est vraiment
dans cette logique là que ça s'inscrit
aussi de le travail d'accompagnement
voilà un peu
un panorama rapide de l'ensemble de ce
que nous sommes amenés à pouvoir faire
au niveau de la Mission laïque française
peut-être préciser aussi un élément
puisque très souvent une des autres
spécificités aussi et à ne vous estimez
dans le cadre de notre de notre réseau
par rapport à aux établissements
nationaux c'est vrai que nous avons tous
les cycles dans un même et seul endroit
très souvent ou en tout cas en capacité
donc on a une capacité là aussi de
travailler sur tous les cycles et de
pouvoir ainsi garantir une vraie
continuité et que ça soit d'ordre
bâtimentaire et que sur aussi l'ensemble
des normes de là aussi optimiser voilà à
la différence où dans nos territoires
nationaux vous avez des collectivités
territoriales qui sont amenées à gérer
chacun des niveaux c'est vrai que nous
n'avons pas cette contrainte là et nous
avons une visibilité totale sur la
capacité à pouvoir gérer tous les cycles
et en particulier tous les enjeux aussi
de formes scolaire je reviendrai sur cet
enjeu de forme scolaire c'est comment
aussi est la problématique à laquelle
nous sommes confrontés c'est comment
associer forme scolaire et en jeu
environnementaux
la question de la forme scolaire est une
question
essentielle pour permettre de d'offrir
des environnements éducatifs adaptés à
la pratique pédagogique et donc comment
nous sommes amenés aussi à faire que ces
contraintes de la forme scolaire intègre
aussi très fortement les enjeux
environnementaux nous travaillons en
particulier avec le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale sur cette question
là qui est un département dédié sur la
forme scolaire avec un site et je vous
conseille de si vous avez pas identifié
ce site là de pouvoir le voilà aller le
voir ça s'appelle archi classe et donc
c'est une offre développée par le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale qui
est très en tout cas pour les
collectivités pour les acteurs qui sont
amenés à développer des bâtiments et en
particulier ces enjeux environnementaux
qui offre tout un panel de solutions en
tout cas un accompagnement spécifique
donc là aussi c'est des choses que nous
sommes amenées à pouvoir intégrer dans
le cadre du de notre fonctionnement
voilà merci merci monsieur matériaux je
vais à présent c'est de la parole à
Monsieur Ronan Le bleu qui me l'a
demandé merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur les directeurs les
établissements français à l'étranger
sont en concurrence parce que il
scolarise des Français mais également
des locaux et puis des élèves de
nationalité tiers et donc vous êtes en
concurrence parfois avec le lycée
américain des établissements locaux et
dans ce contexte de concurrence la prise
de conscience environnementale par les
parents par leur propre enfant
devient-elle un élément de concurrence
vous voyez dans le dans le dans le
critère de choix parmi parmi bien sûr
beaucoup d'autres critères
prix la qualité de l'enseignement la
pédagogie mais mais est-ce que c'est un
c'est un élément de concurrence nouveau
et dans ce contexte il y a une dizaine
d'années le Quai d'Orsay avait inventé
le label ambassade verte est-ce qu'on
peut imaginer que la création d'un label
lycée français vert peut-être dans le
cadre de la stratégie du prochain SPSI
puisse justement devenir un élément
justement davantage concurrentiel pour
les lycées français à l'étranger je vous
remercie
avant que vous ne répondiez passer la
parole à notre collègue central
oui merci beaucoup je voudrais tout
d'abord vous remercier monsieur le
Président et Madame la rapporteur
justement pour avoir permis cette cette
audition ça permet d'inclure dans cette
mission Mathis scolaire justement le
notre beau réseau d'établissement hors
de France et je vous en remercie
moi plus que un questionnement c'est
aussi pour appuyer sur l'un des
principes la principale problématique
qui a été soulevé par le directeur de
l'AEFE c'est vraiment cette
impossibilité qui est faite depuis 2010
d'emprunter qui a un frein non
négligeable donc je souhaite insister
sur ce point auprès de Madame la
rapporteur et monsieur le Président
puisque je pense c'est un point central
et pour tout vous dire notre Assemblée a
voté l'Aude dernière budget un
amendement que nous avions initié sur ce
sujet là donc le Sénat est très sensible
puisque c'est à la l'unanimité nous
avions voté justement pour mettre fin à
ça malheureusement ça avait pas été
possible suite au 49,3 qui avait retiré
cet amendement mais je doute pas que
nous ferons des propositions à nouveau
sur sur ce sujet alors après moi c'est
plus aussi
spécifiquement il y a des problématiques
aussi qu'on a pu percevoir dans certains
pays pour respecter des fois les règles
de sécurité aussi au niveau local il y a
un sujet un peu chaud qui est celui de
l'établissement notre établissement qui
est à Londres Charles de Gaulle
qui a été même étrié un peu dans la
presse mais un mauvais titre d'ailleurs
pas à bon escient mais par rapport au
fait qu'il ne respecterait pas justement
les normes de sécurité au niveau de ce
mise aux normes des de son établissement
par rapport aux règles britanniques
alors je sais pas si vous avez des
éléments précis par rapport à ce type de
situation et on peut être aussi face à
des situations a priori dans certains
pays qui ont l'habitude de vivre des
épisodes caniculaires c'est le cas
notamment en Italie ou autre où il y a
des politiques locales qui sont établies
pour par exemple les élèves ne vont pas
en cours pendant certaines périodes ce
qui n'est pas forcément obligatoire
[Musique]
solution pour nous aussi pour avoir un
levier pour que justement ces
établissements qui sont quand même
conventionnés en partenaire avec nous
puissent aller dans le bon sens par
rapport à la rénovation énergétique et
durable de prévoir dans ces
conventionnements dans ces accords qui
sont signés avec ces établissements
peut-être des règles de ce type-là pour
exiger certaines normes ou certaines
règles par rapport à ces dispositions là
et ce que ça existe à l'heure actuelle
peut-être sinon peut-être nous-mêmes y
réfléchir pour essayer que ça aille dans
ce sens là merci à vous
merci madame le rapporteur merci
juste comme on parlait de norme je
voulais y revenir tout à l'heure vous
avez dit que vous il y avait des pays où
les normes étaient plus importantes que
les nôtres il y en avait ou c'était
moins important que les nôtres quand on
est dans un pays où effectivement la
norme est moins importante qu'est-ce qui
s'applique la norme du pays la nôtre si
tentait qu'il y a tous les matériaux et
les savoir-faire
comment faites-vous pour poser les
normes de la maternelle du lycée du
collège dans un même établissement
est-ce que il y a on applique les mêmes
normes de sécurité chez nous que dans
des pays où effectivement il y en aurait
peut-être moins et même chose est-ce
qu'il existe quelque chose de spécifique
sur les toilettes c'est quelque chose
qu'on sur lequel on revient beaucoup
notamment sur les maternelles et autres
dont on entend parler beaucoup ici je
vous remercie
d'autres questions
moi j'ai trouvé que l'exemple que vous
avez prises que vous avez pris pardon de
du lycée de Lisbonne était assez
inspirant et je demandais si il pouvait
pas en servir de
d'exemples ou de modèle pour
le versant français est-ce qu'il y a des
échanges d'expériences avec le ministère
ou est-ce que vous faites ça dans
en quelque sorte et sans en faire
profiter d'autres
je vous laisserai à présent répondre
vous savez que ça passe vite
il est déjà presque
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs donc pour répondre d'abord aux
questions du sénateur legleux oui
effectivement le bâti le bâti est un
élément important dans la concurrence
c'est évident c'est l'une des raisons
pour lesquelles il faut investir non
seulement dans la maintenance mais dans
la croissance mais il faut aussi
beaucoup investir dans la rénovation et
dans le complément de l'offre que nous
avons alors c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup
dans parmi les EGD beaucoup sont des
établissements de centre-ville qui sont
assez contraints dans leur dans leur
espace on l'a vu par exemple avec
Lisbonne qui fait que par exemple à
l'extérieur on n'a pas des extérieurs
qui sont à la hauteur de 2000 élèves
présents qu'on n'aura pas de piscine sur
l'établissement etc donc ça c'est vrai
que c'est un problème donc dans la
concurrence évidemment nous faisons
attention notamment dès que nous faisons
des rénovations et des et des nouvelles
constructions à avoir des beaux
bâtiments j'aurais dû vous amener le
livre sur les réalisations les 15
dernières années parce que c'est non
seulement l'image de notre lycée mais
c'est un peu une image qu'on envoie de
la France à l'étranger comme pour nos
ambassades et nous faisons très
attention à la qualité architecturale ça
c'est ça c'est sûr maintenant est-ce que
les familles placent la question
environnementale parmi les critères de
choix je crois que par rapport à la
piscine au stade où c'est encore un
degré nettement en dessous après ça en
revanche dans la vie de l'établissement
il y a une très forte attention à
commencer de nos élèves à tout ce qui
fait
l'environnement tout ce qui touche à
l'environnement à l'amélioration il y a
de très forte mobilisation des des
jeunes et des équipes pédagogiques dans
les lycées sur ces questions et ça c'est
évidemment très valorisé mais le bâti en
lui-même aujourd'hui les gens ils sont
sensibles quand on construit en neuf
mais c'est pas obligatoirement quelque
chose qui fait venir je sais pas si
Jean-Marc partagera cet avis par rapport
aux établissements peut-être pour
compléter un peu c'est vrai que on a des
situations très différentes
d'un territoire à un autre et d'une
configuration aussi d'établissements à
un autre c'est à dire que
et donc dans
c'est vrai que dans nos établissements
nous avons une majorité de
d'élèves locaux par exemple et pas
d'élèves français donc ça dépend aussi
de la maturité des parents par rapport à
ces questions en matière
environnementale oui donc ils intègrent
pas voilà alors que la fe a souvent des
établissements où il y a une part plus
importante d'élèves français voilà donc
il y a aussi cette prise en compte là
qu'il faut pas sous-estimer dans la
conscientisation des questions et quand
vous vous trouvez dans des pays compare
encore été amenés à vivre en tout cas à
se poser toutes les questions
nécessaires à l'évolution des bâtiments
institutionnels aux normes
environnementales la prise de conscience
elle est peut-être pas la même et donc
les exigences sont peut-être pas les
mêmes donc ça peut varier d'un pays à un
autre mais aussi d'un établissement à un
autre vous voyez donc c'est ça aussi qui
il est important aussi de de comprendre
dans le cadre de ce que nous sommes
amenés à pouvoir vivre au sein des au
sein des établissements
et c'est vrai que pour pour revenir
aussi sur sur la question même de de la
compréhension alors nous on l'observe
aussi on a fait toute une étude la
marketing
ces derniers temps sur sur le
positionnement de nos établissements
c'est vrai que comme ça a été rappelé
par le directeur de la fe la question du
bâti est importante mais plus sur la
question de l'infrastructure que sur les
enjeux environnementaux clairement c'est
à dire qu'on va regarder avant tout
l'infrastructure plus que la dimension
environnementale
mais cependant on sent quand même que de
plus en plus ça commence un peu à voilà
je vous prends un exemple parce que je
trouve assez symptomatique de ce que
nous sommes amenés à développer un
nouveau complexe sportif dans notre
établissement en pleine responsabilité à
Dallas quand vous allez à Dallas vous
utilisez quand même la clim en
permanence voilà c'est pas totalement en
matière voilà
le complexe que nous sommes en train de
construire sera totalement ouvert n'aura
pas de clim ça sera de ça reposera sur
sur un principe d'aération naturelle et
donc tout ça on voit bien que quand même
il y a des prises de conscience voilà
qui sont prises en compte là aussi bien
évidemment sous notre influence mais pas
seulement puisque là vous êtes sur des
partenariats publics privés et donc
c'est aussi les partenaires avec
lesquels nous sommes amenés à travailler
qui intègrent pleinement et ils savent
aussi que ça peut se dire aussi pour les
usagers en matière de respect
environnemental donc ça c'est des des
exemples très concrets sur lequel nous
sommes amenés à que nous vivons
aujourd'hui et c'est vrai que on sent
bien que cette dimension là commence à
poindre son nez dans des choix et je
pense que là aussi c'est par le
pédagogique qu'on sera amené à faire que
la conscientisation sera aussi
importante et donc aura aussi des
impacts sur les parents à moyen long
terme
sur la question des normes mais je
réponds simultanément monsieur Chantal
et à vous madame le rapporteur
d'une façon générale l'énorme locale de
toute façon doivent être appliquées et
quand elles sont de notre point de vue
trop basse ou voir une existante nous
appliquons les normes françaises alors
pas obligatoirement à tous les niveaux
quand on a des problèmes pour les mettre
en oeuvre mais alors sur les questions
de sécurité ça c'est évident c'est les
normes françaises sont le minimum qu'on
va qu'on va avoir ici d'énormes locales
vont au-delà on les met en oeuvre alors
s'agissant du lycée de Londres c'est une
situation très particulière parce qu'en
fait c'est pas tant les normes de
sécurité de l'établissement que les
procédures liées parce que nous
appliquons strictement les normes
éducation nationale mais les procédures
que love stade demandait n'ont pas été
suffisamment mis en oeuvre et donc nous
sommes en train de corriger et le
bâtiment est en revanche y compris aux
normes sécu de sécurité anglaise de ce
point de vue là donc donc voilà sur ce
point là les adaptations d'horaires de
calendrier oui c'est quelque chose
auquel on réfléchit il y a des endroits
où d'abord c'est déjà mis en oeuvre dans
les pays les plus chauds etc les classes
en tout cas pour le primaire maternelle
primaire peuvent avoir des horaires
aménagés avec des débuts très tôt le
matin et qui se termine pas trop tard
c'est vrai qu'on rencontre toujours les
difficultés en revanche sur le
secondaire parce que les emplois du
temps sont extrêmement chargés et c'est
vrai que nos élèves de toute façon en
comparaison avec tous les autres
systèmes sont toujours pris l'après-midi
dans des classes en cours mais on peut
adapter et pour prendre un exemple très
concret que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
celui de Tunis c'est vrai qu'on est même
en train de réfléchir à l'idée de revoir
peut-être un peu le calendrier scolaire
puisque les épisodes de très très fortes
chaleurs de canicule étant de plus en
plus importante peut-être de décaler un
peu en septembre une rentrée un peu plus
tardive qu'actuellement pour limiter le
risque ça veut pas dire qu'on en aura
pas mais avoir moins de jours de très
fortes canicule ça n'empêche pas d'avoir
une réflexion sur les sur les bâtiments
à mener
je ne reviens pas sur la question du
financement de l'immobilier de l'agence
et a fortiori c'est vrai que vis-à-vis
du réseau je ne sais pas si on est en
mesure de mettre dans les règles de
l'homologation des normes extrêmement
précises sur ces questions là il y a des
normes qui touchent au bâti scolaire que
nous faisons respecter dans le cas de
l'homologation mais qui tiennent à des
normes de taille de classe à la présence
de salles de cours de récréation etc
mais sur les questions touchant à ce
domaine là ça me paraît très difficile
d'avoir des règles strictes en revanche
une politique incitative et de soutien
aux établissements conventionnés
homologués qui permettrait lorsqu'ils
sont engagés dans un processus
immobilier d'avoir une subvention
spécifique nous avons actuellement deux
types de subventions les 15 millions
d'euros que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
ce sont des subventions de sécurité pour
financer les travaux de sécurité dans
les établissements l'installation de
portique de de sas de concertina sur les
murs etc
et des subventions pour le développement
c'est à dire des investissements qui
permettent de renforcer l'attractivité
de l'établissement on pourrait très bien
imaginer s'il est à nous en donnait les
moyens d'avoir également une subvention
sur l'amélioration du bâtisse scolaire à
des fins
d'amélioration et
développement durable nous serions le
mettre en oeuvre je pense que ça aurait
un effet immédiat parce que les
établissements y trouveraient leur
intérêt direct ne serait-ce qu'en retour
après ça sur leur fonctionnement et
Jean-Marc signalaient le cas du Liban
tout à l'heure effectivement nous avons
une enveloppe spécifique que l'État a
voté donc dans la loi de finances
10 millions d'euros d'aide pour le Liban
et sur ces 10 millions d'euros d'aide
pour le Liban 7 et demi sont consacrés
un programme de soutien à
l'électrification solaire pour les 55
établissements du réseau qui sont au
Liban qui sont pour nous tous soit des
conventionnés soit des partenaires on
n'a pas de jeter là-bas et c'est 7
millions et demi d'euros nous allons
mettre en oeuvre avec le soutien de
l'Ambassade vont permettre
l'électrification solaire de tous ces
établissements donc le fait de ne plus
avoir à dépenser des dollars pour
acheter leur pétrole qui permet
simplement d'avoir de l'électricité par
le même pas de chauffage c'est
simplement l'électricité pour faire
fonctionner les établissements et
dégager des marges qui vont leur
permettre de payer leur propre en
dollars pour les garder donc on utilise
le levier développement durable et
électrification solaire pour également
avoir un impact immédiat sur le
renforcement structurel des
établissements des établissements du
Liban voilà la question des toilettes
est une question effectivement très
sensible en particulier dans les dans
les maternelles et donc nous amène à
avoir en tout cas dans tous les projets
de rénovation et à fortiori dans les
projets nouveaux des systèmes je vous
invite si un jour vous passez à Madrid
d'aller voir l'école maternelle vous
verrez ce qu'on peut faire et notamment
sur les toilettes
d'utilisation la façon dont s'est mis en
place entre deux de classe de maternelle
et voilà et puis sur le cas de Lisbonne
non on n'a pas on a je crois pas qu'on
ait eu des changes particulier avec le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale sur
ces sujets on est en échange permanent
c'est vrai que le réseau et l'agence
depuis la loi du 28 février 2022
sont décrits comme étant des
laboratoires mais pédagogiques pour le
compte du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale en particulier dans le domaine
linguistique puisque dans tous les
établissements nous avons une politique
linguistique quel que soit le statut des
établissements qui est bien plus avancé
que de qu'en France sur l'immobilier on
n'a pas encore de référence de cette
nature il peut y avoir des échanges mais
c'est vrai que pour le moment la taille
de notre réseau enfin Odile dirigeait
les s'occupait des lycées
d'Île-de-France auparavant donc elle
peut comparer entre les lycées
d'Île-de-France et le ceux du réseau
notre réseau c'est du coup humain quand
même à chaque fois alors après ça si on
a des belles expériences on est tout à
fait prêt à les faire connaître
et puis le ministère n'est pas
constructeur au niveau des bâtiments
techniques donc il peut donner indiqué
des préconisations il a d'ailleurs fait
par le biais de sa cellule batiscolaire
mais il est pas constructeur donc il y a
pas de référentiel absolu sur la façon
de construire un bâtiment ce sont les
collectivités qui mettent en œuvre en
France territoriale avec la cellule
Bathie scolaire en fait si vous avez des
bonnes expériences ça peut être
intéressant en fait de leur montrer
puisqu'il produisent un certain nombre
de guides tout à fait
c'est un peu prévu en fait
et puis sur les toilettes enfin je veux
pas revenir sur un sujet c'est toujours
extrêmement sensible mais il n'y a pas
de règle
comment dire d'usage et de conception
sur les toilettes en France pour les
bâtiments scolaires voilà donc on se
base sur un au niveau du réseau parce
que j'ai on a des questions beaucoup
très très récurrente là-dessus on se
base sur les obligations du Code de la
Construction en France et du code de du
travail parce que c'est là qu'on a les
plus les meilleurs références en fait et
sur bien sûr la réalisation technique
c'est les règles de l'art quand on
réalise un ouvrage avec des évacuations
et tout ça et puis sur les bâtiments de
notre réseau effectivement les toilettes
c'est toujours un sujet donc on
intervient on rénove nos toilettes quand
même très régulièrement pour que ils
puissent voilà puissent donner
satisfaction laisse pas dépérir les
espaces toilettes
on est dans un monde très concurrentiel
un étranger et il faut sans cesse
s'améliorer
la qualité du service de l'accueil et
alors la maternelle qui ça vaut pas
évidemment tous les établissements et
Jean-Marc de pourra dire que la même
chose la maternelle qu'il apporte
d'entrée dans le système éducatif
français c'est le domaine dans lequel on
doit se concentrer aujourd'hui le plus
pour avoir d'un bâti au niveau attendu
parce que c'est là que les familles
viennent voir la différence entre les
établissements et si on rate les enfants
maternels on lui peut récupérer un peu
plus tard mais étant donné que les deux
tiers des élèves du réseau
d'enseignement français les Français
sont des étrangers dont une grande
partie de famille non francophone c'est
à la maternelle que ce qu'est la
francophonie donc il faut pas les rater
or la maternelle et dans un monde de
plus en plus concurrentielle et ça ne va
plus de soi aujourd'hui de dire que
l'école maternelle française et la
meilleure du monde il y a de très bons
systèmes concurrents et donc nous il
faut qu'on améliore sans cesse et le
c'est souvent du côté de l'immobilier
que ça pêchait jusqu'à présent
peut-être pour compléter sur les
toilettes je pense qu'il y a aussi en
particulier sur la question
environnementale tout un enjeu
d'utilisation de des eaux et en
particulier des eaux de pluie pour
l'alimentation des toilettes et donc je
pense que ça c'est des enjeux aussi très
forts à souligner en tout cas nous on y
travaille aussi fortement en particulier
à 10 à débats c'est une problématique
sur laquelle on est fortement là aussi
de voir comment on peut utiliser les
autres pluies pour permettre d'alimenter
l'ensemble du réseau et en particulier
l'eau des toilettes donc je pense que
sur cette question environnementale
c'est aussi une dimension importante
dans les dans les autres pour revenir
aussi un peu sur les normes et sur la
question de la hiérarchie des normes si
on pourrait appeler les choses comme ça
il y a une dimension aussi c'est que
c'est vrai que nous et à travers notre
emprunt pro parcours pour parcours nous
demande obligatoirement d'avoir les
normes internationales d'accord donc les
trois normes c'est HQE Edge et Breham
donc suivant là où on se trouve où on
doit une de ces normes internationales
et on ne peut pas voilà c'est vraiment
des voilà notre emprunt est lié à à la
mise en place de ces normes-là donc là
aussi donc du coup on est sur on est
plutôt sur du haut de panier on pourrait
essayer parce que moi c'est chaud dedans
strictement lié au bâtisse scolaire ou
de manière générale à la construction il
y a tout dans les normes de
cellier à la construction dans lequel il
y a tout un volet sur
les normes environnementales et donc en
particulier le HQE qui intègre aussi
cette dimension environnementale très
fortement donc voilà mais peut-être que
tu voulais préciser
vous demandez l'emprunt vous devez en
fait prouver que votre bâtiment répondra
à ça OK et puis après on a un gros suivi
c'est à dire que trois parcours
en fin de compte sont très à cheval donc
on doit avoir des rendus on doit il y a
des visites de chantier il y a oui donc
c'est pas c'est un suivi très très fin
de la part de pro parcours et puis si on
n'a pas été amené à
respecter les normes ils nous donnent
pas la suite de l'emprunt quoi vous
voyez donc on a intérêt de respecter
donc ils ont des méthodes coercitives
ils ont des méthodes coercitives très
voilà
qui qui sur lequel on est obligé de
respecter quoi
[Rires]
quand je trouve que vous avez l'air de
rénover quand même beaucoup malgré
malgré les contraintes c'est il y a vous
avez une idée du nombre d'établissements
que vous rénovez complètement sur
oui
ça fait beaucoup de tranches parce que
on rénove rarement complètement en une
fois un site sur les 68gd ça constitue
100 de sites donc ça veut dire plusieurs
corps de bâtiment et plusieurs parcelles
sont bien souvent donc en fait on
intervient en réparation très souvent
parce que c'est entre guillemets
l'entretien courant on essaie d'avoir
toujours des bâtiments qui sont entre
guillemets propres qui ont même un bel
aspect qui font envie mais ce sont pas
des interventions
comment dire consistante sur avec une
prise en compte générale de l'ensemble
des sujets bâtimentaires donc
actuellement
le bilan des spécifs précédents donc on
était sur des sur des horloges par sous
votre contrôle mais de entre 100 et 150
millions d'euros sur 5 ans
de de pour des travaux lourds ou des ou
des constructions des rénovations là on
est en train de travailler sur le
troisième SPSI pour le moment on est
dans la phase encore de la lettre au
Père Noël et puis après ça on va
regarder le budget parce que quand on
regarde ce qu'il y aurait à faire sur
notre réseau c'était à peu près 300
millions d'euros qu'il faudrait faire en
5 ans si on voulait faire les choses
correctement évidemment on sera pas sur
ce sur ce volume
on sera nettement en dessous et ça va
dépendre de si on est toujours obligé de
travailler sur la base des de la
capacité de d'augmentation des fonds de
roulement des établissements j'imagine
qu'on dépassera difficilement les 70 80
millions d'euros sur les sur les 50 qui
viennent parce que les familles nous
pour nous ne pourrons pas demander un
effort voilà vaut mieux sans 100
millions mais ça va être difficile
d'aller au-delà et pour sur le premier
SPSI on était sur un volant d'une
quarantaine d'opérations 195 millions à
l'époque donc 2010 et sur le deuxième on
était sur un boulot de 110 millions pour
23 opérations qui n'ont pas toutes été
mises en oeuvre et qui ne sont pas
terminés donc pas complètement financé
parce que l'un des problèmes du fait nos
difficultés de financement c'est qu'on
est obligé de saucissonner et ce qui est
la fin à la fin ne revient plus cher
puisque on est obligé de faire des
tranches successives pour
contenu de la soutenabilité pour
l'établissement des travaux engagés et
donc ça fait des projets qui durent sur
15 ans 20 ans qui coûte plus cher à la
fin et qui sont un vrai problème parce
qu'ils compris en fin de SP ici on a
encore beaucoup d'opérations qui sont
en cours ou même pas encore engagés
[Musique]
il y a plus de questions moi j'aurais
une question
parce qu'on constate qu'en France les
communes ou leur regroupement
de plus en plus souvent sont amenés à
ouvrir
l'accès au bâtiment scolaire en dehors
du temps proprement scolaire
pour différentes raisons d'ailleurs il
faut savoir si c'était aussi le cas dans
je sais que l'étranger c'est pas
homogène
ça serait et si ça c'est des pratiques
que vous constatez dans certains pays
alors évidemment très variable en
fonction de des conditions de sécurité
il y a des établissements dans lesquels
évidemment limite au maximum tout entrée
extérieure
dans l'eau Sahel ou ailleurs ça va être
soit que une autre bâtiment sont de plus
en plus
protégés
renforcés après ça oui on essaye dans la
mesure du possible de d'accéder alors il
y a traditionnellement des associations
sportives qui vont utiliser le terrain
etc je pense qu'on le fait tous
dans le cadre par exemple j'ai en tête
la nouvelle piscine qu'on a ouverte au
lycée de Casablanca il y a ils ont prévu
donc une location
à des associations le soir et le
week-end qui vont permettre disons de
baisser un peu le coup de fonctionnement
de de la piscine grâce au grâce aux
rentrées donc oui ça se fait c'est pas
une source de revenus majeur pour les
établissements mais à la marche ça peut
aider en particulier c'est vrai que
quand il y a une piscine qui est
installée si on peut l'ouvrir c'est
mieux parce que ça fait partie des
établissements des des structures les
plus coûteuses pour les établissements
donc on peut donner un exemple qui est
celui de Séville que nous sommes en
train de créer en fin de compte dans la
négociation qu'on a eu avec la région et
la mairie de Séville
on a réussi à obtenir un prix défi un
peu toute concurrence sur le prix du
terrain pour nous permettre mais à
condition qu'on fasse un lieu ouvert
d'accord c'est à dire que
donc on a pensé un projet qui a un
projet ouvert sur la ville dans lequel
on met un établissement français et donc
on a pensé à un donc c'est un centre
français d'innovation et technologies
puisque on est au cœur de la Coupe
d'Europe qui est l'ancienne
espace de l'expo universel de 92 et donc
on est amené à créer un centre français
d'innovation des technologies dans
lequel on met un établissement scolaire
et c'est grâce à ça aussi qu'on va
permettre de pouvoir avoir une vraie
ouverture et une vraie donc ouvert avec
un FabLab ouvert avec un certain nombre
d'autres
services et disposition
un incubateur aussi de société on va
avoir plein de choses qui vont permettre
aussi de créer un vrai continuum entre
voilà des formations en particulier sur
tout ce qui concerne les thèmes donc les
sciences technologies ingénieries et
mathématiques et pour nous permettre là
aussi de pouvoir élargir réellement les
partenariats locaux donc là c'est un
vrai projet totalement ouvert alors bien
évidemment avec les contraintes parce
que bien ayant particulier sur la
maternelle puisque c'est là aussi très
brillant c'est-à-dire vous devez
sécuriser avant tout donc on a des flux
de gestion de la gestion des flux qui
constituent un enjeu aussi très fort
dans le cadre de ce type de projet
très bien merci beaucoup merci de votre
participation des informations que vous
nous avez transmise je rappelle que le
débat peut encore se prolonger que si
vous aviez des choses à
compléter vous serions bien sûr
intéressé par par ces choses là en
attendant je vous souhaite une
excellente après-midi
merci à vous